こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆様お待たせいたしました
紙編集
初めで遊ぼうコンテスト2020に
発表会
皆様をお待たせいたしましたちょっと前に
ですねあの動画を編集してほしいと皆様の
紙編集を見せてくれと僕から動画を2本
この動画を編集してほしいっていう動画を
2本皆さんにお渡ししました1本目が
こちら
右左右左右
右こんにちは
右左右左右左右左右左右左そして2本目が
こちら
あー喉乾いたなあ
[拍手]
うまい
盾と横の動画になってるんですけどもこの
2本は皆様の手で紙編集
編集してもらいたいということでたくさん
の作品が
届いております動画は編集してくださった
皆様本当にありがとうございます今から
その紙編集された動画を皆さんと一緒に見
ていくわけなんですけども何名か選ばれる
んですけどもなんと選ばれた方には
100万円攻撃100万円の商品があり
ますので是非お楽しみにでは早速見ていき
ましょう
はいというわけで早速皆さんの作品見て
いこうと思います100万円かかってる
から結構大事なんすよなんか色々結構精査
して著作権ゴリゴリ無視したりいやその
音楽ダメでしょみたいなバリバリ著作権
引っかかるようなものとかも全部省いて
ちょっと見せることが可能な中そして
面白いなと思ったものを順々に見ていき
たいと思いますはいというわけで早速
コンテストの動画も見ていこうと思います
まず1作品目ですねいきますよさあ来まし
た
はじめ
[音楽]
壮大だな
誰誰誰
肉
全世界中の問題を解決する
革新的な技術はじめ
右か左
右左右
こっちが何なんですかって言いたいよどう
いうことなんだ何を伝えたいんだ何それ
メッセージが強いというか
CMっぽいというかクオリティが非常に
高かったんですけどもなんなんですか何な
んすか逆に俺が聞きたいです素晴らしい
ですこれでは高かったですありがとう
ございますで次いきます
喉乾いたなぁこれ
あー
[拍手]
[音楽]
うまいいやすごい切れ抜き技術すごい俺が
普通に冷蔵庫開ける動画の俺の部分だけ
切り取るんですけども結構むずいんすよね
その切り取りがめっちゃ多分時間かかっ
てると思いますいや素晴らしい恐竜食べて
たな次いきます
[音楽]
すげー雨降ってる
こんにちはー
[音楽]
[拍手]
買い物してる動画ですね
すごいなもう勢いがいやクオリティ高
なんか18禁のアニメが好きみたいな感じ
になっちゃってるのかこれいやすごい先に
でしたありがとうございます次いきます
[音楽]
おー始まった
何これ
[音楽]
すごいこんにちは
怖い
[音楽]
フルーツあー宇宙だ
宇宙だねこれもう
[音楽]
大丈夫か
何が点々だよちょっと待ってよいやすごい
勢いが
いやーすごいなんかしっかり技術を見せ
つつもちょっとクレイジーさもあるあと
なんか結構あのパワープレイというか編集
な暴力みたいなものを感じてすごい僕結構
好きですねこれありがとうございます次
行きましょうおー
8ビアの泉
大人気YouTuberはじめしゃちょー
はい
宇宙人と
交信したことが
[音楽]
誰
実際に
聞いてみた
[音楽]
あれほど完璧なぁ
すごい凝り方がちょっと驚きましたね
あーはいはいはい動画に入れてほしいって
言われたんですけどまあ僕たちが言うのは
あれなんですけどちょっと
危ないとか
目の危険を感じたので
宇宙人がさちょっと断りましたね
こうしてこの世界もまた一つ
新たなあー
すごい
もう別に自分で撮影されたんでしょうね
実写を
右左
交信の子合図だったんですねなるほど
ぶっ飛んでますね次の作品ですどうぞ
音楽かっこいいついにあの男が
ギター
世界最大級の
ベストを開催するんだ俺
すげーかっこいい
うまい
[音楽]
まくってもよし
77年後
すげー初音ミス2099を
うまいことを作りましたね
素晴らしいいや上手いな結局なんかあの
素材だけだとなかなか表現できる
量が少ないのでいろんな素材で足して
すごい素敵な
フェスの開催が77年後皆さんお待ちして
おります次の付近ですどうぞ
いきなり右左右こんにちは
右左右左右左右
左右左右左
大戻ってきて戻ってきたなんだなんだ
おー
右
左右
上下
逆なのをくっつけてますねこれ
右左右左
[笑い]
しょうもないけどおもろいわ
賢いですねなるほどねこれは技ありですね
結構凝った編集こそが紙編集みたいな
ところあると思うんですけどもこういう
ちょっと一工夫しただけでは面白かったり
するんですよいやすげえな分身するし
こんにちはで顔の位置がぴったり俺の顔が
たくさんピュってこんにちはで出てくると
かすごい面白かったですうわー素晴らしい
面白いテキストも無しでこの面白さ
素晴らしいです次ですどうぞこんにちはー
[音楽]
なるほどなるほど
個人的には好きですねなんかじわじわと
その面白い感じが来るのが個人的に好き
ですねあとちょっとメッセージ性がないの
が逆に
好きです次ですどうぞこんにちはー
[音楽]
ナイズで不合格
こんにちはこんにちは
ちは
じわじわじわじわじわじわ違う
こんにちはー
受からなかった作ってた気がしたんですよ
ねいやすごい目動かすときに俺右左って
言わないと目動かないタイプの人間のやつ
ですね
うん
次です
果物が出る
不思議な冷蔵庫どうぞ
乾いたなぁ
なんか出てるね
[音楽]
[拍手]
シンプルシンプルシンプルシンプルに果物
でまとめてやるいいしねなんかこうお手本
的な感じでこれも大変なんですよこれ作る
のいやーありがとうございます次の作品
ですどうぞ
すごい
すごいすごい
めっちゃけてる
すげー
すごいこれは
合成っていうかあの僕だけ切り抜いて
たくさん
ええとはじめが現れたみたいな感じで編集
されたんだと思いますいやすごいなんかね
こういう凝ってるんですけどもなんかその
物量で凝るというよりこういう1つの技術
で笑わせるみたいなやつすごい素敵だと
思いますありがとうございます次です
どうぞ
喉乾いた
なぁ
すごい
これ
吸い込まれちゃったけど冷蔵庫にいや
素晴らしいこういうのできるんだね編集で
いやー素晴らしいありがとうございます次
の作品ですどうぞ
[音楽]
[拍手]
あーなるほど面白い
どういう頭してんだろういやいい意味です
よいい意味で猫めっちゃボツ見てたし
ちょっと不思議なムービでしたね
ありがとうございます
次の作品です右左と言えば視力検査だなと
いう安易な考えから動画を作ってみました
ありがとうございますご覧くださいどうぞ
これからお前らには
視力検査を行ってもらうただし4問答え
られなければ奈落の底だ
[音楽]
[拍手]
次ですねそれを見たら映画予告という
タイトルですどうぞ
見つけた
うわすげーなよくあのしょうもない外で
こんなの作れるなあ
すごいなあいやしっかりホラーになってて
ちょっと感動しましたありがとうござい
ます次ですどうぞおー
すごい手持ちいいから始まったな
うおお
何これ何これ何これ
すげえもうイラストやん最後の方すげー
何これどうやって作ったのいやいやいや
ちょっとなんか
すごい人が出てきましたねこれちょっと
どんどん見ていきたいと思います次の作品
ですどうぞ
[音楽]
出てくる
うまいうん
シンプルですねなんか模範解答みたいな
あの編集の仕方ですねいやでもこれも凝っ
てて時間かかったと思いますありがとう
ございます次の先ですどうぞ
[音楽]
近いよ
事故
事故っぽいけど
顔が
近いよ
使いって
はじめしゃちょーのサークの家再
リフォームしちゃいました
へー
隠しコマンドを実行してみた
[音楽]
壁に達成に下がる埋め込まれてますと
ここで温泉入力
[音楽]
隠し子ですねこれ
認証されました
すげーロケットしていた
ミサイルも平気になりましたでも
軌道に時間かかりすぎ
次は良い字使わなきゃ
ごちそうありがとうございました
いい日使いますね
[音楽]
喉が渇く初めての
すごい凝ってる
[音楽]
すげー
爆発者最後あれ
エンドまで出てくるんだ
[音楽]
可愛い
すげーありがとうございます
これはすごいわなんか俺の大きさを小さく
したら大きくしたりして冷蔵庫から出て
くるなんか可愛かったすね見ててなんか
笑っちゃったなー
すごい素敵ありがとうございます
可愛らしいセンスあるなぁ
次ですえちょっぴり奇妙な現象ですどうぞ
乾いたなぁいいスタート
開けた
すごい合成で食べちゃった
うまいいやシンプルですごいこの方初めて
編集されたみたいでありがとうございます
冷蔵庫の中のもの買えるとかでも結構
難しいのですごい時間かかったなと思うし
ほんとすごい上手にできて
感動しましたぜひ今後も編集してみて
くださいありがとうございます次の作品
です人気YouTuber始めしゃちょー
現行犯逮捕課
htk放送
逮捕されるの俺ご覧くださいどうぞ
[音楽]
登録者1000万人を超える大人気
ユーチューバーの男が
女性の自宅の敷地に無断で侵入したとして
現行犯逮捕されました
右左右逮捕されたのは
静岡県内に住む男性枝初め容疑者29歳
です
容疑者は今月1日に
同県内に住む女性の自宅の敷地に無断で
侵入右左と叫びながら
壁を殴るなどした疑いが持たれています
なお[ __ ]容疑者は登録者1000万人を
超える大人気YouTuberはじめしゃ
ちょーとして
若者を中心に絶大な人気がありました
が
警察の調べに対して
餌容疑者はとにかくいらついていた
自分の格子で家が更地になるのが見たかっ
たじゃないかもう
なるほどいや面白いすごい
編集とかもすごい凝ってましたし
入手っぽい動画作るのって結構時間かかる
んですけどもしっかり作られてましたね
あとニュースキャスターがあの最後
拳でさらすにするところで笑ってるところ
とかもすぐ個人的には面白かったです素敵
です次ですどうぞ
花咲くはじめコンクリに花を咲かせ
ましょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
おーすげぇ
鼻咲いとるなぁどうやってやってんだろ
これすごいすごい次の先にですどうぞ
乾
いたなぁ
[音楽]
どうぞはじめ独身の階段を登るという結婚
までの道のり音楽
流れてる
左右左
[音楽]
どこまで行くちょっと待って待って
どこまで行くの
結婚まずいっちゃうけどこれあ戻ってきた
あれ
すげーできないんかい結婚できないんかい
これいやでもすごいななんか合成で階段を
延長させてるんでしょうねこれパッと見何
かわかんなかったけどよく見たら階段が
繋がってて結婚というゴールまで
続いてるんだなあ
すごい
階段を延長させるというこの発想力ですね
面白いなんか次すごいな初めて株式会社で
は秘密裏に人型クローンの研究が行われて
いるらしい最近では量産戦闘型の研究が
進んでおりはじめしゃちょーの野望は
とどまるところを知らないすごいないや
ご覧くださいどうぞ
見つけました
Cブロック5番通路ですよね
ま
さか映像出ます
監視カメラ風になってる
あ俺だ
なるほどロボットなんだこれ
に立ってます
どうぞ
戦闘員創意貢ぐ
現在逃走中の
ヒトマル300000は
Cブロックを経由し
屋上へと進行中だこのまま市街地に被害が
出ることは免れないだろう
[音楽]
すげー
[拍手]
強制的に俺の口を動かすという技術ですね
これはすごいよなかなかできないことだと
思いますね登場人物全部僕でしたねなんか
ストーリーあんだけ単調な動画をこれだけ
ストーリーに落とし込むっていうのはもう
本当に才能だと思います
面白い
次の作品ですどうぞ
いきなり来た
[音楽]
真ん中に移動した
あれあれなんか指が
指降ってんねん
どうやってこれしたの日本三大だし東京
大阪
静岡にした
静岡にしたよ俺
であー
[音楽]
背景ボケてるんだけど
フィン
いやすげー
[拍手]
編集というかなんか口を強制的に動かし
たり俺の手をこうやって動かしたりとか
もうこれはすごいですね多分わざわざ腕を
切り抜いて動かすようにしてるんですよ
編集で
すごいしなんかちょっとやっぱ才能を感じ
ますね
すごい次の作品ですどうぞこんにちは
こんにちはこんにちはこんにちは
加速してる
ニコニコニコニコおー
[笑い]
[音楽]
すげーこの加速するのってなんかシンプル
に見えるんですけど結構編集大変だったり
するんですごいないやパワープレーですね
これパワープレーションですこれ次の作品
ですどうぞ
光が
あれなんかスロット始まったけど
こんにちは
ゆうたら大当たり
言えるかな
確定だねこれも
[音楽]
こんにちは確定しますねこれ
が
いやーすげー
パチンコの確定みたいになってましたね
これは相当凝ってると思いますよ
本当だったらこの人外れバージョンも入れ
たかったらしいんですけどもその60秒
以内っていう縛りがあったので条件で
当たりだけにされたみたいですわっ外れも
見てみたかったなあ
すげえCR始め社長ですありがとうござい
ます次の先にですどうぞ
[音楽]
めっちゃリアルななんか何これ
砂みたいな水
床が海みたいになってたねすごい次の先に
ですどうぞ
ヒビ入ってね
えっ
ラップ街の次元爆弾はじめしゃちょー参上
[音楽]
ラッパーになってんだこれ
すごい
あー爆発しちゃった
耐熱性の高いサングラスなんだ
すげー最初割れてるし
触ったコンクリートいやちょっと
クオリティ高すぎて怖いですねもうここ
まで来るとすごいありがとうございますで
は次の作品ですどうぞ
ー
どういうこと技術はすごいのわかるけど
なんかすごいなんか芸術展高めな作品です
ねなんか何時にも重なっててうちの
キッチンが広く見えました次の作品です
どうぞ
ドッペルゲンガーって知ってる
自分のそっくりさんでしょ
すごいね
チャットしてるみたいになってますねで
やっちまったらそれ術後にはあの雪だって
よこんにちは
人生を乗っ取られてしまうという説もある
らしい
そう奴らは獲物をじっくり観察して
左右
これドッペルゲンガーなのかその時が
来たら
喉乾いたなぁ
[拍手]
[音楽]
すごいよくあの素材をだけどどんな素材で
も自分の世界観に持ってくっていうのが
なんか僕はすごいなと思いますねいや
怖かったシンプルにありがとうございます
この方も初めての動画編集だったみたい
ですね
初めてでこのクオリティ作るってすごいな
この方ありがとうございます次の先にです
どうぞ
[音楽]
星伝説かべりいつも壁に持たれて歩く男が
いた
俺だねあれとのために
[音楽]
可愛い女性が浮かび上がったおー
すごいねこれ作ったのかなこれもう
[音楽]
食べに行って214
右左を18回手をつきながら歩くあで俺が
それを実践するという
なるほどね
都市伝説をなんか実際やってみるみたいな
ね
じゃあこれ緊張するな会えるんかな壁に
1回多かったね
あれれ
どうなっちゃってんのこれ俺めちゃくちゃ
ぼやけてたけどこの世から消えちゃっ
たって感じなのかないやこれは初めての
編集みたいですねすげーありがとうござい
ます
凝ってるなあ次の作品ですどうぞ
問題まずはこちらをご覧ください
右左
右左から出てくる
[音楽]
左左右こんにちは
左左左で
[音楽]
本当とかめっちゃ可愛いな
ぁ
いじめられてるいじめっ子たちに
浦島太郎逃げろーあー大丈夫だよ
助けてくれてありがとう
の素材だけ使ってる
はじめは
浦島太郎は
竜宮城へ向かいましたと
すごい
竜宮城でいっぱい遊びましたそして
初めは
お
姫様から
冷蔵庫ら
帰っても冷蔵庫を上げないでねそうね
[音楽]
開けた
[拍手]
お
じいちゃんになっちゃったその声が
聞こえたら
本格的何
ホラー調だねあなたの隣に何かが
来る
r15
なんか
可愛い音楽流れましたけど
全ての左右が
傷つくるっていうか
[音楽]
声が始める新しい世界
LR左右ってことね
すげーめっちゃぽいの作りましたねいやー
これも
素晴らしい技ありでございます何俺のあの
左右は妖怪が何かなのかな結構なんか洞戸
に作ってくださる方は多くて嬉しいような
ちょっとなんか複雑な気分ですありがとう
ございます
次の作品ですどうぞ
[音楽]
はいはいはい
腕出てきた
[音楽]
冷蔵庫の中に俺がいる
うまい
すげー
[音楽]
小さくなった冷蔵庫の中ですごいさっきも
冷蔵庫吸い込まれたなったんですけどこれ
その後冷蔵庫の中で生活してっていう
うまいにも繋げてましたねいや
すごいいやこれは凝ってるなあすごいです
感動しましたもう俺の素材を元からこの
ために取ったんじゃないかみたいな使われ
方しててなんか1つのなんか正解なような
感じもしましたねすごい発想力だなこれも
さあ次の作品ですどうぞ
[音楽]
汚いやろ
こんにちはこんにちはー
[音楽]
[笑い]
暴力暴力的編集だねすごいなあ
凝ってるって言えばわかんないですけど
すごいなんかいろんな編集をされてますね
ただうんちゃん来てないです
[音楽]
喉乾いたなぁこの後始め社長に奢る
トラブルとは一体何でしょうえー何だろう
冷蔵庫から
殴られる
喉乾いたなぁ
ぴよぴよの評価食べてる
国産下に
[音楽]
えー
星になっちゃった
笑いありがとうしんどりやないか
しんどりやないかよ俺これ
[音楽]
すげー
いやこれ冷蔵庫の中に出てきた僕も
しっかり影のエフェクトというか影も入っ
てて
めっちゃ自然にね
合成されてたというか
違和感のない合成そしてひよこを食べる
ところのズームとスローこれただ者じゃ
ないんですねこの人分かりますよ俺はいや
凝ってますねこれいや素晴らしい作品です
すごいあんなしょぼんない人代表ここまで
いろんな方がすごいことにしてくれてる
やばい次の作品ですどうぞ我々に届いた一
つのVTRそこに映っていたものを
読んだすごい
我々調査隊は静岡の奥地へと向かった
すごい探検隊があれが
右左こんにちは
人間じゃないですかあれのどこかすごい
合成ですけど
きっと
襲った人間から
教わったんだろう
うまくねえよ
奥行ったぞ追跡の
えーすごい
消えましたねこの聖水爆でも仕掛けて
奴が化けもやしだと暴く
喉が渇いたタイミングで
すげー
正体洗えて
あれで
美しいだったなはいあれじゃ春にしか食え
ねえないやそういう問題じゃなくて
[音楽]
すげーんだよこれ
完全探検隊の動画になってたなその僕の
細かいなんか喉乾いたなとかそういう発言
もうまいこと動画で取り入れてこうやって
作品にされてるのはマジですごいですね
よく考えて作られてるんだと思います
ありがとうございますすごいなあ
嬉しいよこんなの作っていただけたら本当
に次の作品ですどうぞ
おーなんかすごいショートっぽいな
ショートムービっぽい
おー
[拍手]
食べたあ
すげー
次の先にどうぞ
サンジのおやつ
[音楽]
俺の魂なんだこれ
本当に怖い
そんな時
[音楽]
々さんが作ったんですね
世界観すごいなぁ
ホラー調ホラーより上のなんか別の地毛に
行ってますね
病院に行きましょうさあ最後の先にです
どうぞあ
男子トイレだこれ
はいはい入った
[拍手]
前回の前回の素材を使うな前回の素材を
使うんじゃないよこれ前回のボスは素材も
使ってますねこの人いやでもありがとう
ございます
はいというわけでたくさんの作品本当に
ありがとうございました
全部じゃないんですけどもほんとしていき
ます作品がたくさんあって見てて参考に
なりましたしてすごい僕も勉強になりまし
たそして本当に技術のある方初めて編集さ
れた方でもAdobeを使ってこんなに
編集できるんだっていうのがすごいわかっ
てまだまだ編集動画編集って無限の可能性
があるなと思いましたで本当に素晴らしい
作品たくさんあって僕もまだ判断がつか
ないのでちょっと色々考えてどれにどの賞
をあげるかもちょっと考えたいと思います
ではまた後日
[音楽]
お待たせしましたこんにちははじめしゃ
ちょーですあれから
月日が流れ
早5年ようやくノミネートされた作品の中
から始め賞を5名そしてアイディア賞を3
名K
8名の方を選ぶことができました
非常に難しかった非常に難しいですしもう
できれば全ての作品にあげたいんです
けれどもそういうわけでもいかず心苦しみ
ながらもなんとかはじめ賞5名
賞金10万円アイディア賞3名選ばせて
いただきましたので早速発表していきたい
と思いますまずはじめしゃの5名から紹介
します
賞金10万円ですよまずは1人目かっこ
速報人気ユーチューバーはじめしゃちょー
現行犯逮捕課htk放送おめでとうござい
ます
いやこれは面白かったですねもうその
ニュース番組っぽくあの動画素材をまとめ
られたのが本当に
感動したというか僕自体ああいうちょっと
面白いニュース動画好きなんで結構僕の心
に刺さりました素敵な作品ありがとう
ございます10万円おめでとうございます
続いて2人ですこれはもう俺は入れたかっ
たですね
初めに株式会社秘密裏に人型クローンの
研究が行われてるらしい最近では量産戦闘
型の研究が進んでおりはじめしゃその名簿
は止まるところを知らないでそれでござい
ます
けどねいい意味でこれはもう
びっくりしましたねどうやったら僕の会社
が人型クローの研究をしてい
るっていうところにたどり着いたのかと
映像も非常に面白くなんか僕の顔の靴を
無理やり動かすっていうのがすごい
滑走力というかなんとかしてねとても
素晴らしいと思います入賞おめでとう
ございますそれで3作品目適当に作った見
ての通り
某ギャルに影響されてますですおめでとう
ございますこれはですね
男子がとても可愛かったですねこうなんか
指減ってる感じのダンスをあの映像に
落とし込むそれがまた面白いと相当センス
を感じましたねこれ本当に適当に作ったの
かってぐらいちょっと
個人的には面白いでしたね
想像力そして音楽も僕好きでしたお
めでとうございます
続いて4人目
フェスのCM風おめでとうございます
[音楽]
よくあの映像よあのしょうもない動画を
フェスのCM風に落とし込んだなと思い
ましたなんかほんとフリーの映像も
たくさん入れ込みつつけど僕の謝罪も
しっかり生かしてはじめしゃちょーのお店
があったんじゃないかと思うような作品
作っていただいておりますありがとう
ございます2019年に乞う期待です最後
の1名です最後の作品は
初参加です自分なりにノーサイヤ人の力を
出し切りましたですおめでとうございます
これはもうなんか僕の
模範解答ってわけじゃないですけどもそれ
に近いような感覚かなと思いました冷蔵庫
を使って動画編集をするんだったらどう
いうのを考えるかなって思った時も本当
なんか絵に描いたようなこれがやって
欲しかったみたいなやつがバーンって出さ
れた感じすごい編集も凝ってて見やすくて
面白かったですおめでとうございます
ここからはアイデア賞3名の紹介ですまず
1人目増殖初めですおめでとうございます
[音楽]
細かいテキストとか合成技術とかはなくて
いいと
初めてもう増殖させるだけでいいんだと
パワーですよパワー編集なんでもう
面白ければOKっていうのも心がたくさん
来ました
本当になんか僕も影響を受けたというか
アイデア一つで面白いものを作れるんだな
と思いました増殖するだけで面白い
追及された作品
洗練されておりますおめでとうございます
2人目仮想化するはじめしゃちょーですお
めでとうございます
やっぱね
凝ってる作品はもちろん面白いですし見
やすいんですけどこの何加速させるだけで
こんなにも面白くなるのかと編集の奥深さ
凝るだけが攻めてはないっていうの
しっかりと
体現してくださいました本当にねもう
スピード感で速さの暴力これ速さの暴力と
いっても過言じゃないくらい突き詰めたね
本当にありがとう
ございます
愛だっていうとこうなっちゃうんだよね
やっぱ尖ってる作品が多くなっちゃうね
そして最後の1人です
文字通り始めましたちょっとで遊びました
編集楽しいお
楽しんでくださいましたおめでとうござい
ます
冷蔵庫からちっちゃいはじめしゃちょー
たくさん出てくるという動画なんですけど
もこれはもう本当に純粋に凝ってますね
じゃあちっちゃいはじめしゃちょー
たくさん出すのも難しいしそれを第1章の
大きさ変えて出てきてなんかそのねもう
攻撃の巨人感があってすごい
可愛らしく冷蔵庫の中から出てくる
思いました素晴らしかったですはいという
わけでいかがだったでしょうかこういう
感じで無事作品発表会終わらせていただき
ます本当に面白かったねやっぱねー
自分の思いつかない編集の仕方とか見ると
本当に
刺激を受けて
すごい今回僕自身も楽しかったですまた
機会がありましたら商品100万円でお
会いしましょうバイバイ
できればですけど
[音楽]